- [Gary] Everybody always want
to think everything is either
dead or alive.
It's not that binary.
- 'Cause I remember
Vine, Vine's over, Vine.
- But when Vine's hot.
Listen, back in the
back in the back day
you would've loved to be on TRL.
- [Ferg] Right.
- [Gary] Diddy built his
whole fuckin' thing on TRL.
Now you don't
want to be on TRL.
- [Ferg] Yeah.
- 'Cause it doesn't even exist,
let alone anybody watching it.
So to me, Vine would
have been amazing.
I wish you were the
number one artist on Vine.
- [Ferg] Hmmm.
- Not even artist, like person.
You know why?
You'd be making
$40 million a year right now.
- [Ferg] Mhmmm.
If you take all
300 million Americans
and you asked them to sell
this bottled water and they had
unlimited budget,
I believe that 90% of Americans
would make a TV commercial.
- Hmmm.
- Or do a billboard.
- And that's some bullshit.
- Correct.
- Yeah.
- What I would do with my money
is I would give it to a bunch of
influencers on Instagram and
I would make one or two great
videos for Facebook,
three minutes long and
that's what I would do.
- And that's exactly what these
big corporations
is doing like Nike.